Dans un épisode précédent,
l’agriculture faisait peser des menaces sur la société humaine.
T'arrête !
Surcharge de travail, maladie, dépendance aux ressources,
l’agriculture était un fléau.
Plus jamais je ne te laisse faire mes intros d’épisode.
Et pourtant l’agriculture est une voie qui est empruntée par la plupart des sociétés humaines,
et du coup la question se pose de…
Bienvenue au Vortex, moi c’est Clothilde pour le premier épisode d’une série sur quelques grandes révolutions de l’histoire humaine.
Alors, non, on ne va parler ni de la Prise de la Bastille ni de la Bombe Atomique, mais de choses bien plus fondamentales.
Vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi de Vinci a pu peindre la Joconde ?
La Préhistoire.
Et pourquoi Kennedy a été assassiné ?
Et pourquoi... la Préhistoire.
Aller, on remet tout dans l’ordre,
comme l’agriculture est à peu près la plus grosse claque qu’on se soit pris dans la tronche de toute notre Histoire,
il fallait bien deux épisodes pour tout expliquer.
Bon d’abord il faut dire une chose, quitte à briser le mythe,
mais l’agriculture n’est pas une invention.
Aucun chasseur-cueilleur ne s’est jamais réveillé le matin en se disant :
« Tiens ,si j’me mettais à planter le manioc devant la maison
plutôt que de me casser le cul à en trouver dans la forêt ? ».
Ensuite, personne n'a jamais fait la découverte du principe de l'agriculture.
Tous les peuples de la Terre,
Ô LORD !
Même ceux qui ne cultivent... nan, je peux pas.
Tous les peuples de la Terre, même ceux qui ne cultivent pas
connaissent le principe de la reproduction végétale.
La fleur donne le fruit qui donne le noyau qui donne la plante, etc., etc.
C'est pas à des gens dépendant des ressources végétales pour leur nourriture
que vous allez apprendre ça.
La plupart des cueilleurs encouragent d’ailleurs la prolifération des plantes
qui leurs sont utiles quand ils les croisent,
en répandant leurs graines, en éliminant leurs parasites
ou en coupant leurs parties malades.
Ces procédés existent partout
et il est donc impossible de parler d'une invention
comme pour la machine à vapeur ou le mélodica.
Ces quelques gestes sont en réalité la base des soins qu'un agriculteur prodigue à ses cultures.
Et d’ailleurs,
c’est l’heure de la cueillette !
Ma question, c’est de savoir si l’agriculture est seulement une invention humaine
ou... y a une fourmilière sur le pied de Ronan.
C’est pas grave…
- C’est pas grave…
Ou si y a d’autres espèces qui cultivent.
Et bien, ça tombe bien que tu parles de fourmi,
parce que justement, ouais, les fourmis cultivent.
Elles cultivent des champignons.
C’est les fourmis coupe-feuille
Elles coupent des feuilles des arbres et puis on voit les colonnes de fourmis qui ramènent les feuilles dans la fourmilière.
En fait, elles donnent les feuilles à manger à un champignon.
Le champignon grandit et en échange,
le champignon donne des sortes de petits bulbes à manger aux fourmis.
Elles s’en occupent, elles le taillent, elles enlèvent les parties infectées, etc.
Elles le désinfectent, parce qu’elles ont des bactéries qui produisent des antibiotiques.
Et, en plus, y a de la sélection.
- Tu ne m’aides pas à ramasser ?
- Non.
- Tu me laisses faire ?
- Ouais. Je ne sais pas faire moi.
En plus, il y a plein d’autres espèces.
T’as les poissons qui cultivent des algues.
T’as plein d’espèces de scarabées qui cultivent des champignons.
Est-ce qu’il y a des exemples, alors là, pas avec du végétal, mais avec de l’élevage ?
Tu as des fourmis qui élèvent des pucerons en fait.
Elles récupèrent le miellat qui est excrété
par l’anus du puceron et elles vont récupérer le miellat
avec leurs petites mandibules à l’anus du puceron
et elles vont se nourrir avec.
- D’accord.
On se la fait cette confiture.
Franchement avec ça, non, je ne suis pas sûr.
On va au supermarché ?
On achète des vraies mûres ?
Ouais.
Des framboises, ou quelque chose d'autre.
C'est dégueulasse.
Vous avez compris mon argument,
le principe est connu partout, et depuis toujours,
même au-delà des frontières du genre humain.
Il n'en reste pas moins que ce type de vie n'est pas celui des premiers humains,
qui étaient des prédateurs.
En adoptant l’agriculture, les humains ont dans leur histoire franchi un cap,
ils se sont mis à jouer le rôle de la nature,
c'est-à-dire celui de veiller à sa place
à ce que les animaux et les plantes se reproduisent.
La raison pour laquelle ils ont fait ça, c'est parce que la nature ne fournissait pas de rendements assez constants.
En gros, elles faisaient mal le job.
Ils ont donc commencé à la remplacer,
mettant ainsi le doigt dans un engrenage infernal.
Pour continuer à bénéficier de ce que la nature leur donnait avec abondance auparavant,
ils devaient désormais produire un travail considérable,
pour simplement maintenir les rendements de la cueillette sauvage.
Résultat des courses : nos chasseurs cueilleurs avaient du pain en quantité
mais ils s'étaient fait piéger, ils étaient devenus agriculteurs,
avec tous les inconvénients dont on a parlé la dernière fois.
On voit qu'en réalité, on ne devient pas agriculteur par plaisir ou même par choix.
On devient agriculteur sans s'en rendre compte
et parce qu'on a quasiment pas d'autre alternative.
Ce que l'on appelle à tort « invention » de l’agriculture
c’est en fait un processus long, qui a lieu sur plusieurs générations.
Mais pour que ce processus puisse s’enclencher,
il faut d'abord un climat adapté, c'est-à-dire un interglaciaire.
On l'oublie souvent, mais l'apparition du genre humain
est concomitant d'une succession d'ères glaciaires et les périodes tempérées dites « interglaciaires »,
sortes de parenthèses chaudes, ont été très minoritaires.
Ce n’est pas un hasard donc si l'agriculture est apparue pendant une période chaude, l'Holocène ,qui a débuté il y a 12 000 ans.
La chaleur et des espèces sauvages à domestiquer,
c'est un bon début, mais il faut aussi et surtout des conditions sociales.
Avec des animaux comme les humains, on ne peut jamais se satisfaire d'une explication biologique ou environnementale.
Désolé Léo.
Tout passe toujours par le prisme de la culture et de l'organisation sociale.
La preuve rapide que l'agriculture n'est pas qu'un fruit des conditions naturelles,
c'est que l'Holocène n'est pas le premier interglaciaire que connaît l'espèce humaine
Durant l'interglaciaire précédent, le « Riss-Wurm »,
qui est survenu il y a environ 130 000 ans,
personne n'a inventé l'agriculture.
Pourtant, les Sapiens ou même les Néandertaliens
connaissaient bien à cette époque le principe de la reproduction des végétaux.
Si l'agriculture est apparue il y a 10 000 ans
et pas 130 000, c'est qu'il y avait des conditions sociales qui n'étaient pas réunies la première fois.
Reste à savoir lesquelles.
Comme souvent en sciences humaines, c’est complètement illusoire de chercher une cause unique.
Les facteurs sociaux qui ont permis à plusieurs sociétés d'inventer l'agriculture à peu près au même moment
à l'échelle de l'histoire humaine, sont forcément multiples.
Parmi les différentes hypothèses qui ont été avancées pour expliquer, par les structures sociales, l'apparition de l'agriculture,
il y a notamment celle du chercheur français Jacques Cauvin,
qui avait proposé que se soit déroulé une sorte de « révolution symbolique »,
en somme un bouleversement des mentalités,
visible dans l'art des sociétés préhistoriques.
Mais encore une fois cette hypothèse n’est pas suffisante.
Les découvertes matérielles que nous avons se heurtent à la chronologie.
Est-ce que c’était avant, après, pendant, tout du long... bah ce n’est pas facile à dire.
Pour l'américain Marshall Sahlins, ce serait plutôt l'apparition du pouvoir qui motiverait la création d'un stock,
et donc d'une production agricole.
Encore une fois, difficile de démêler la cause de la conséquence.
La plupart du temps en préhistoire, c'est du côté de l'ethnologie qu'arrivent de nouvelles idées stimulantes.
L'anthropologue français Philippe Descola a lui pris le problème à l'envers,
en étudiant des sociétés qui ont justement décidé de ne pas basculer dans l'élevage.
Dans son article « Pourquoi les Indiens d'Amazonie n'ont pas domestiqué le pécari ? »,
Descola considère que l'élevage du pécari (alors c’est un genre de petit sanglier)
aurait modifié trop en profondeur le rapport des Indiens animistes aux animaux.
Pour les animistes, les animaux et certaines plantes sont spirituellement similaires aux humains,
toutes les espèces peuvent prendre l'apparence d'autres et elles entretiennent des relations sociales très complexes.
Genre, moi, je pourrais être un pécari ?
Oui, tu pourrais, mais ton aloe vera aussi pourrait être aussi un pécari.
- Cool !
- Tu te rends compte ?
Exercer sa domination sur une espèce que l'on conçoit comme son égal pourrait ainsi compromettre l'équilibre de la nature.
Pour cette raison, les Indiens d'Amazonie n'ont pas domestiqué le pécari,
mais n'ont en revanche eu aucun mal à domestiquer le chien,
un animal arrivé assez récemment avec les Européens,
qui ne peuplait pas leur mythologie, et donc avec lequel ils n'avaient pas de relations à préserver.
La condition principale de l'émergence de l'agriculture, celle qui fait qu'une société accepte de mettre le doigt dans l'engrenage serait,
si on suit cet exemple, une mutation dans les rapports entre les humains et leur environnement.
Les plantes et les animaux ne seraient plus investis d'une dimension spirituelle,
mais deviendraient comme des objets qu'il est possible de manipuler.
Dit comme ça, c'est assez révélateur du rapport de nos sociétés industrielles à leur environnement.
L'idée que tout est disponible pour l'exploitation humaine naît et se développe en même temps que la Révolution néolithique.
La Révolution industrielle n'est rien d'autre qu'une accélération technique,
l'état d'esprit reste fondamentalement le même.
Cette mentalité développée à l'échelle du capitalisme mondialisé avec 7 ou 8 milliards de consommateurs n'est,
on le sait tous maintenant, absolument plus viable.
Les prises de conscience récentes tentent ainsi d'enrayer dix mille ans d'histoire humaine,
pas facile de faire émerger les prémices d'une nouvelle Révolution.
C’est la fin de la vidéo.
Merci à tous de l’avoir regardé.
Vous pouvez laisser des commentaires,
mais aussi nous retrouver sur le Discord
pour discuter de cet épisode et de la série.
Et puis bah lâchez un pouce bleu,
Et puis, à la prochaine. Salut !